her name is karen
and she's not very happy
this two-ton rhino does not want to be
held
in a concrete pen
but an international team of scientists
have picked her
for an extraordinary experiment and if
successful
karen may save a species from extinction
yeah anesthesia is always dangerous in
these kind of animals
and then rhinos in particular frank
goretz is a scientist with a steady hand
and we found him getting ready to knock
the rhino out
ready let's go he fired two darts
filled with sedative at a spot just
behind karen's left ear
immobilizing the animal in less than 20
minutes
then the scientists got to work trying
to turn this rhino
into a mother with fertilized eggs or
embryos
created in the lab cross our fingers we
are quite optimistic
but for sure in my heart
i i'm pretty sure that we succeed
the future of the northern white rhino
may depend on it
it is one of africa's most magnificent
animals
but after decades of poaching they are
effectively
extinct sky news filmed the last
mail called sudan just before he died in
2018.
there are two remaining females but
neither can reproduce
but dr thomas hildebrandt and team think
they can rebuild this subspecies
with science
they've used frozen sperm and eggs
collected from northern white
rhinos to create a small number of
precious
embryos but they don't know the best way
to use them
we have created so far three embryos
transferable embryos from the northern
white rhino
but before we do the full procedure to
transfer
into a surrogate mother we have to know
that the system is working
that's where karen comes in scientists
are trying to create the first
test tube baby in a less endangered
southern white rhino
like this 17 year old
and we watched as they tried to plant an
embryo
in her uterus or womb they lost it on
the first attempt but this microscopic
organism
was discovered in a plastic tube and
they managed to implant it
on their second try
it's all about angling and you know
little details so we attempted a second
time and then
at that time the the catheter really
went into the uterus very smoothly and
we tried to put it very very close to
the ovary to the oviduct
and yeah now it's up to her
and the scientists told us there were
grounds for optimism
in the yard they'd used a sterile bull
called kimber to stimulate karen before
the procedure
the timing seems to be really good the
bull has uh
indicated us that he was interested in
her about four or five days ago
and he seemed to be right about this
if anybody knows then he should know
however karen has taken a different view
of the proceedings
she survived the experiment finding her
feet after an
unexpected snooze but the pregnancy has
failed we understand
karen will not carry a calf and the
scientists
must find another way to resurrect the
north and white rhino
john sparks sky news